una campaña contra lo que se conoce como
el caldo de cultivo del terrorismo el
ministro del interior llega al dogma nin
confirmó que se realizarán inspecciones
en 76 mezquitas sospechosas de promover
puntos de vista radicales o extremistas
en algunas zonas particulares existen
espacios de culto que son claramente
anti republicanos
qué quiere decir con eso son lugares
donde los imanes están bajo vigilancia
de los servicios de inteligencia y donde
el discurso va en contra de nuestros
valores como la igualdad entre hombres y
mujeres son lugares donde hay
antisemitismo odio contra los católicos
odio contra francia y que tienen una
financiación que parece más que
sospechosa la investigación se centrará
en la financiación de las mezquitas y en
los antecedentes de imanes considerados
sospechosos y buscará evidencias sobre
escuelas coránicas para niños pequeños
la medida se adopta como respuesta a los
recientes ataques terroristas entre los
que destacan la decapitación del
profesor samuel para ti y el asesinato
de tres personas en una iglesia de niza
sin embargo esta operación ha sido
acusada de atacar injustamente a la
comunidad musulmana
divisamos en busca de 2500 mezquitas y
lugares de culto en francia hablamos de
76 mezquitas es decir menos del 3% por
desgracia la minoría que falla es la que
llega a los titulares
sentimos que las decisiones del gobierno
están fuera de lugar el islam vende es
la obsesión diaria de algunos políticos
algunos funcionarios electos y algunos
medios de comunicación para los cuales
somos su principal negocio como hong
kong ex en octubre el presidente francés
emmanuel macrón anunció una ley contra
el separatismo religioso con el objetivo
de según dijo liberar al islam en
francia de las influencias extranjeras
el proyecto de ley que será examinado en
la reunión del gabinete del próximo
miércoles es visto de forma mayoritaria
por la oposición como una concesión a la
extrema derecha y está provocando
airadas protestas en los países y
comunidades musulmanas que han acusado a
las autoridades francesas de
intolerancia